[Musique]
aérobic c'est la nouvelle folie de l'été
non ce n'est pas une marque de stylos
c'est une gymnastique venue de
californie une gymnastique qui se danse
et qui commence à faire fureur sur la
côte normande à bout de plage un bon
rythme disco et une demi-heure
d'exercice quotidien
le cocktail est garanti avec ça vous
aurez vite un corps d'athlète
à quoi ça sert de faire faire de la
gymnastique aux gens sur la plage bien
on s'est aperçu que les plats je manque
un peu d'animation
donc ils s'ennuient alors pourquoi pas
me les occuper sainement et essayer de
le faire faire de la gym la gym tout
seul c'est dur car les gens simples
fainéants donc turgis musical la musique
les amène automatiquement à faire les
mouvements sans qu'il s'en aperçoive
c'est là le petit secret de la gym danse
[Musique]
avec la russie à bientôt 70
vous venez ici tous les jours à tous les
joueurs depuis le début et on ne lui
passe c'est une heureuse initiative
j'avoue que arrive un moyen fort
longtemps je viens d'arriver bella et
j'avoue que
de cette année j'ai trouvé que c'était
une très heureuse initiative d'ailleurs
d'après leurs résultats qu'ils en ont
oui il ya du monde est pour quand le
temps est pas tellement tellement
brillant si vous voulez tout le monde y
vient pour quoi faire de la gymnastique
sur la plage on peut passer de sport
dans la journée j'en fais beaucoup de
trop mon cher qu'une femme j'ai des
enfants et des petits enfants jouent
énormément on va quand même il ya une
question de souffler si vous voulez de
de travail des débuts ce qu'on ne sait
pas travailler si vous voulez
normalement est habituellement qu'elles
ont fait travailler ici c'est bon tout
ce que c'est ça pour le corse entretien
petit peu les muscles qui marchent pas
beaucoup tout au long de l'année
et puis je sais pas ça au bord de la mer
c'est agréable
[Musique]